CYP2C9 is important in the pharmacokinetic pathway of
Warfarin. So let's learn a bit more about
how it goes from gene, to protein. CYP2C9
can be found on chromosome ten of the human
genome. Chromosome ten is about 135 million base
pairs long. And the CYP2C9 gene can be found
towards the end of the chromosome. The CYP2C9
gene itself contains nine exons spanning more than 50,000
base pairs of DNA. After transcription and
splicing, the resulting MRNA contains 1473 nucleotide
decoding region between the start and stop
codons. And then after translation, you end up
with a protein that has 490 amino acids. There's one allele of the CYP2C9
gene that's associated with enhanced Warfarin efficacy
and potential toxicity, and you can see that
allele here, the change from an adenine to a
cytosine at position 1,075. Now, using the genetic code we
learned about in lesson three, and which you can
find in the instructor's notes on this page. I want
you to determine the change expected in amino acid
sequence here. And then select the type of mutation that
best categorizes the cytosine allele. If you have trouble
answering this. Go back and review mutations from lesson six.